ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: WE ARE ROOTING FOR
YOU.
ENES FREEDOM, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: A FOX NEWS ALERT
FOR YOU, OF TO JUSTIN IN THE
CASE WE TOLD YOU ABOUT LAST
NIGHT, THE CASE OF THE MURDER OF
ST. LOUIS POLICE CAPTAIN DAVID
DORN.
WE ARE REJOINED BY KEVIN CORKE
WHO HAS THE STORY FOR US.
>> JUST FINDING OUT ABOUT THIS
ONE FROM THE GREAT CITY OF
ST. LOUIS, CITY JURORS FINDING
HIM GUILTY ON FIRST-DEGREE
MURDER CHARGES AND SEVERAL OTHER
CHARGES IN THE 2020 KILLING OF
RETIRED ST. LOUIS POLICE CAPTAIN
DAVID DORN.
IT ONLY TOOK THE JURY THREE
HOURS OF DELIBERATION ON THE
THIRD DAY OF EVIDENCE AND
TESTIMONY.
CANNON WAS THE REAL COWARD IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE.
HE CROUCHED DOWN AND SHOT DORN
TEN TIMES AS LOOTERS ATTEMPTED
TO LOOT LEE'S JEWELRY AND PAWN
SHOP.
DORN WAS 70 YEARS OLD, DOING
WHAT HE COULD TO MAKE A LIVING
AND TRY TO SAVE THIS BUSINESS
WHICH WAS UNDER ATTACK.
HE WAS MURDERED SENSELESSLY.